[Musique]
cette invitée aujourd'hui c'est vous
Hervé Terry bonjour bonjour merci d'être
là vous êtes géographe professeur à
l'Université de Sao Paulo directeur de
recherche et méritos CNRS on va revenir
avec vous bien sûr sur les résultats de
ce premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle au Brésil 1er tour à
l'issue duquel ni le sortant en
bolsonaro ni le revenant Lula n'ont donc
obtenu la majorité absolue il y aura
donc un second tour ce sera le 30
octobre prochain pour les départager
Lula est en tête le report de voix a
priori lui est favorable mais c'est loin
d'être le raz-de-marée que certains
annonçaient les carrés bien plus minces
que ne laissez penser les sondages
encore ces dernières heures quoi avant
le scrutin comment est-ce que vous
analysez ces résultats
important car elle donne aussi peut-être
la tonalité de ce qui va se passer dans
quatre semaines et là on va revenir dans
un instant vous êtes géographe c'est
important de le redire et là on est sur
un pays sur ces élections générales qui
est coupée quoi en deux en trois en
trois plutôt puisqu'il y a le sud et le
Sud-Est qui ont voté plutôt bolsonaro le
nord-est et une grande partie du Nord
amazonien qui ont voté pour Lola mais il
y a des parties d'une heure du de
l'Amazonie les front pionniers le Centre
Ouest qui ont voté très massivement pour
bolsonaro ce sont des gens qui sont pour
la liberté d'entreprendre et de déboiser
et donc eux ils trouvent leur héros ils
sont pour le port des armes ils sont
pour toutes sortes de choses que là dans
certains coins il a fait certains états
il a fait 70% avec un soutien
enthousiaste des gens qui sont là pour
une sorte de Far West où ils sont
enthousiastes de ce genre de proposition
voilà sachant que les populations
autochtones de ces régions de l'Amazonie
très opposée on le sait à la politique
de destruction environnementale du
président
bolsonaro pèse peu dans le collège
électoral un petit peu moins d'un
million sur 210 millions de Brésiliens
donc malheureusement ils ont ils pèsent
pas beaucoup les défenseurs de la forêt
ne se résument pas eux il y en a
d'autres aussi mais ils sont submergés
dans ces régions là pas très peuplées au
total mais l'arrivée de migrants qui
viennent pour des boisés qui viennent
pour s'enrichir les ont submergé
complètement
faire une dynamique en faveur de jaillir
bolsonaro qui est donc 8 points neuf
points au-dessus de ce que les sondages
les sépenser est-ce qu'il peut
théoriquement remporter la
présidentielle il pourrait radinamer que
je suis pas sûr il y a un écart par
rapport à ce qui était prévu mais est-ce
qu'il est en train de monter ou
descendre c'est un petit peu difficile à
savoir il a en fait essayé pas mal de
choses qui ont échoué les unes après les
autres d'augmenter la distribution
d'argent d'urgence ça a eu un certain
temps puisse retombé il a fait des
discours très agressifs le 7 septembre
le jour de la fête nationale c'est un
peu retombé donc je crois qu'il joue
toutes ces cartes et je vois pas très
bien qu'elles sont ses réserves
c'est-à-dire que les le troisième et le
quatrième candidat qui sont derrière et
qui sont des réserves de vote il leur
manque très peu il manque un peu 1% et
demi à Lola et lui il lui manquerait 7
mois il y a pas 7 % dans les deux
suivants on a beaucoup parlé de
syllogomme et ce qui déteste Lula et ses
électeurs souvent aussi par contre
Simone t'es bêtes dont on parle pas
beaucoup elle
plutôt penché du côté de Lula enfin il
hésite un peu mais je pense que les
réserves sont là en particulier dans la
région clef qui est le sud-est là elle a
fait presque 9% et c'est là qu'elle
réservoir c'est à se demander quand même
un qui après 4 ans de présidente
bolsonaro la crise du covid et le qui a
été très mal géré par le président
bolsonaro la crise économique et donc
cette appauvrissement du Brésil ces
dernières années le vote bolsonaro n'ont
pas qu'il n'est pas compréhensible mais
de quel est quel est quel est son moteur
est-ce que on peut encore dire que c'est
aujourd'hui un vote protestataire est-ce
que c'est un vote antilou là qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce vote bolsonaro
aujourd'hui je vais vous faire une
petite liste Trump Orban Salvini il y a
ce genre de vote
n'a pas été n'a pas été réélu en tout
cas
non je crois qu'il y a vraiment un vote
de anti-système en protestataire toutes
sortes de gens qui qui rêvent assez
glorieux peut-être mec Brésil great
again ce genre de choses donc il y a
vraiment des gens qui sont crispés qui
ont peur de la de la montée des gens
plus pauvres que il y a toutes sortes de
raisons qui se souviennent d'un passé
glorieux tout ça c'est une sorte de base
assez commune dans beaucoup de pays le
Brésil est exceptionnel pour beaucoup
d'aspects mais il ressemble aussi à
d'autres et on a aussi un effondrement
de la droite classique comme ça s'est
produit dans d'autres pays enfin le on a
un équivalent du vote Pécresse avec
Gérald walthmine qui était le
l'adversaire de Lula dernière fois qui
est maintenant de son côté et dans
l'état de San Paolo pour la première
fois en 20 ans le PSDB ne n'a même pas
n'est même pas au deuxième tour donc
c'est un peu sur cet espace dévasté de
la droite classique que progresse
l'extrême droite au Brésil comme dans
d'autres pays d'ailleurs ici
est considéré comme un dirigeant
d'extrême droite Esco Brésil c'est le
cas les notions de droite et gauche
fonctionnent moins bien au Brésil je
pense que c'est pas c'est plus mon vote
personnellement pour quelqu'un on
l'appelle c'est partisans on l'appelle
le mythe il se trouve son deuxième
prénom c'est Messi à le Messie donc ça
aide un peu mais c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment du vote personnel quand même
avec l'idée qu'il est plutôt du côté des
riches et Lula plutôt du côté des
pauvres il y a quand même cette idée là
qui est un peu le fondement quand même
de droit de gauche mais ça les critères
sont pas exactement les mêmes qui sont
deux dirigeants que tout oppose et
pourtant qui ont des origines sociales
relativement proche Lula et wolsonaro
ils sont pas nés tous les deux avec une
cuillère d'argent dans la bouche alors
un vous le disiez il s'agit de
personnalité pour le coup quand Lila
Lula pardon a quitté le pouvoir en 2010
il était un niveau de popularité
délirant 90% je crois est-ce que là il
paye les affaires de corruption qui lui
ont valu un deuxième passage en prison
c'est-à-dire qu'il a été inéligible
autrefois ce qui a ouvert le chemin pour
qui avait été une énorme surprise bien
plus que cette année la dernière fois
mais en fait il a payé le prix de la
corruption du parti c'était une
corruption systémique c'est-à-dire que
les gens du PT ont beaucoup détourné
pour acheter les députés du centre et
quand on dit je vais je regarderai plus
près les résultats des législatives vous
avez raison c'est crucial et des
gouverneurs et des sénateurs il y a
plusieurs élections en même temps
j'ai entendu dire tout à l'heure vous
étiez la majorité mais je pense que
c'est largement ce qu'on appelle le gros
centre le sentran qui sont des gens
prêts à se vendre plus offrants si Lula
gagné les rejoindra probablement mais
ils vont demander des choses en échange
alors il y a quatre semaines avant le
second tour ce sera le 30 octobre
prochain est-ce qu'elle a lumière de ce
qui s'est passé cette dernière semaine
on peut s'attendre à une campagne de
l'entre-deux-cours de d'entre-deux-tours
extrêmement virulente virulente oui mais
je pense qu'il y a au moins une petite
bonne nouvelle c'est que les bol
sonoristes ont pas intérêt à faire des
échafs fourrés ou des violences
puisqu'ils ont maintenant l'espoir de
gagner dans les urnes alors si comme il
est assez probable il perd on sait pas
ce qu'ils feront après l'élection mais
pour l'instant ils ont plutôt intérêt à
se tenir à carreau
bolsonaro critiqué le système de vote
électronique on regarde des résultats de
cette nuit qu'il ne l'a fait cette
dernière semaine alors il avait menacé à
plusieurs reprises de ne pas reconnaître
les résultats à des urnes là ce n'est
pas le cas mais qu'est-ce que ce sera
dans dans 4 semaines est-ce que s'il
perd le 30 octobre on peut s'attendre à
un scénario à l'américaine pour le coup
il a dit plusieurs fois si les élections
sont propres élections Lim passe tout va
bien sinon je ne sais pas bon donc il
laisse cette petitesse planer ça on peut
imaginer quelque chose du genre Capitole
un coup d'état j'y crois pas beaucoup
l'armée a plusieurs fois manifesté que
non non c'était pas ça les intéressait
pas beaucoup mais comme il a facilité
l'accès aux armes et qui a beaucoup de
milices avec des gens très excités on
peut avoir quelques craintes
effectivement on peut être inquiet merci
beaucoup Hervé d'être venu ce matin sur
le plateau de Paris direct en suivra
donc c'est 4 semaines de campagne qui
commence tout juste au Brésil c'est
encore le milieu de la nuit là-bas sur
France 24 bien sûr merci encore on se
retrouve nous juste après le journal
avec Damien coquet pour la suite de
Paris direct à tout de suite
[Musique]